This is my friend Laura, and she's 80 years old.
And this is my friend Tiffany, and she is 26.
And we live in a retirement community.
I'm a part of the artist in residence program at Judson Manor,...
...which is a residential program where young musicians get to live here rent-free...
...in exchange for performing recitals and concerts.
When I tell people I live in a retirement community, I get a lot of mixed reactions.
Some people don't believe me, other people think it's a wonderful idea.
I had not been a part of this community more than two days.
I was in the lobby and they told me about Tiffany,...
...and I walked over and introduced myself, and I said, "Do you like dogs?"
Oh, she loves dogs.
And Tiffany and I became friends.
We just formed a friendship.